what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right what's going on guys we are
about two weeks out from the Justice
League movie and of course my job is to
make sure you guys are prepared for the
movie itself and so in this video we are
going to be covering the character of
Steppenwolf now Steppenwolf is a weird
choice to choose for a villain in the
Justice League film especially a movie
as high-profile as this because we've
never really had a Justice League movie
on this scale before so it's kind of a
weird choice to choose I personally
would just chosen like Darkseid but
neither here nor there
Steppenwolf made his first appearance in
DC Comics and New Gods issue number 7
and 1971 and he was created by Jack
Kirby now Jack Kirby's an interesting
scenario when it comes to the character
of Steppenwolf or Willie when it comes
to DC Comics as a whole the whole idea
about Jack Kirby and really the basis
behind the New Gods goes all the way
back to the relaunch of Marvel Comics to
a degree now the reason why I say
relaunch is because one of the things
that a lot of casual comment book fans
don't know is that Marvel as it existed
in the 1960s it's not the first time
they popped up Marvel goes all the way
back to the 1940s but they were called
timely comics and after timele came
Atlas Jack Kirby was one of the guys who
really helped to sort of pioneer timely
comics back during the 40 so he was not
new to counter books when he first came
along but the whole idea was that you
know alongside Stanley Jack Kirby helped
to create a lot of the more prominent
characters that exist in Marvel Comics
now the problem with this was that when
it comes to the comic book industry as a
whole
by and large it's usually just writers
who received a credit for Jack Kirby he
wasn't necessarily giving the kind of
recognition that Stanley was getting
because of this I would say in 1970
be basically left Marvel and went to DC
and the idea was that Jack Kirby wanted
to basically launch something called the
fourth world now the fourth world was a
concept that that Jack Kirby had been
messing around with for years before he
left Marvel but it was something he
never really had license to create a lot
of that was because of the fact though
the characters that were coming out of
Marvel were coming out super fast you
know the comic book industry was kind of
experiencing this second Renaissance but
regardless the whole idea of Jack Kirby
was to create something wholly different
and wholly unique and that's important
because in Superman number 76 Batman is
Superman met for the first time in DC
Comics and because it was so well
received DC created a shared universe
meaning that from that point going
forward Batman's Superman
woman with flash Barry Allen they would
start crossing over into each other's
stories which was huge the whole idea
was at a 1961 in addition to this Barry
Allen introduced the concept of the
multiverse and so with that came all
these different alternate realities but
what Jack Kirby wanted to do was
basically come along and say there's all
the superheroes that exists in the main
DC multiverse then there's this whole
other Ashkelon that exists way out there
in the middle of nowhere now the whole
idea was to basically call the fourth
world because it was isolated from all
the superheroes he did this over the
course of three stories the first was
the forever people the second was mr.
miracle and the third was New Gods the
forever people introduced things like
the anti-life equation mr. miracle
focused on basically mr. miracle as a
character New Gods focused on all the
other stuff and that was the importance
of it you know the problem is that for
the character of Steppenwolf he didn't
really have any major significance in
that story with the original New Gods
line of comics one of the things that
was already established is that you
basically had highfather of New Genesis
and darkside of apocalypse and much like
Jack Kirby's themes with like tales of
Asgard in the old for back up stories
the whole idea of the New Gods was to be
this sort of incoming book
representation of good versus evil and
so one of the things that have been
established is that hi father over the
control of the of the the people on New
Genesis had already gone to war
previously with dark side of Apocalypse
the caveat to this was that within the
New Gods line of stories themselves they
also had a guy by the name of you get on
now eunuch Han was basically the father
of Darkseid is really all it was he was
basically the god of gods one of the
most powerful beings to ever exist the
issue was that he was looking for
immortality and so Kirby wrote him out
almost immediately by having him merged
with something called the source wall
which is basically just this wall that
barricades the source kind of like this
source of all life energy that exists in
DC it's sort of interesting it's kind of
strange the whole idea is that when you
could come out of the picture what it
did is it left his wife to basically run
the entirety of apocalypse on her own
but Darkseid himself basically sought to
overthrow her and so with the New Gods
having gone the war previously and the
war more or less having been quelled
what it did is it basically launched the
story with the idea the darkside was
trying to relaunch this war yet again
and that's where Steppenwolf came into
the equation because of the fact that
Darkseid was looking for ways to
basically topple his mom as ruler
apocalypse and then re instigate this
war against the New Genesis what ended
up happening is in an attack on New
Genesis proper
Steppenwolf under the direction of
Darkseid had killed the wife of hi
father and what this did is it said hi
father on a collision course with
Apocalypse itself and that's the most
notable things Steppenwolf did at least
under the writing of Jack Kirby that was
one of the most notable things he did
because of the fact that Steppenwolf was
at general and in the first and his
first appearance at issue number seven
was established as being the uncle of of
Darkseid all he ever did was just what
he was told that was really about it I
mean he was basically the field guy and
the first appearance he was killed right
off the bat by hi father and then
resurrected by Darkseid and that was it
I mean there was it really wasn't a
whole lot to it than that
now that continued really until about
1976 when Jack Kirby left DC ended up
going back over to Marvel again now the
rumor mill about why he left DC was just
the idea that DC wasn't giving him the
right kind of credit they weren't really
treating him as the guy that had helped
to pioneer a lot of the things that
Marvel Comics because that Kirby left
went back to Marvel worked there for a
couple of years and then left but the
whole idea of the New Gods basically
continued on this path was Steppenwolf
being this general being sent in by
Darkseid facing off against some forces
ultimately being defeated that really
just kind of continued on until 1985
with crisis on Infinite Earths now there
were a few things were introduced you
know when it came to the character of
Steppenwolf along the way things like
you know he was basically leader of
something called the dog the dog
squadron of the dog battalion or
something like that
basically like these war dogs but at the
end of the day he was just kind of a
yes-man he was more of a whipping boy
but in 1985 when DC came along and
totally revamped the entirety of their
landscape the new gods were revamped
along with it and that's when we started
running into complications because the
whole idea was that with the new gods
existing outside of all space and time
outside of the multiverse itself crisis
on Infinite Earths was designed to get
rid of all that it was designed to
eliminate all those things not only that
because of the fact that Kirby had left
and DC had decided to take all the new
gods concepts and roll them in directly
to the main line of Super Heroes
allowing Superman at these various
characters to face off against Darkseid
DC had written itself in a kind of a
quandary because now they had to answer
the question if the new gods exist
outside the multiverse but the
multiverse doesn't exist anymore
then how do they justify the existence
of the new gods well the answer to this
question was to basically come along and
say that the new gods existed out in the
universe but that somewhere along the
line their galaxy a quote-unquote had
been blockaded off and that was really
yeah that's the reason why nobody could
get to get to them
and that's the reason why they could
only leave their universe through these
teleportation devices called boom tubes
that was really the answer to that
question but going forward between 1985
up until really the new 52 Steppenwolf
was in the same situation yet again
Steppenwolf being in charge of the
forces of Darkseid going into battle for
whatever Darkseid scheme may happen to
be usually getting defeated and that was
really about it there were a few things
that he did here and there
in the mr. miracle vol 2 series he was a
villain in that story but again it was
it was by and large just kind of a
character that didn't really need to be
there one of the things that was crazy
though was that during the events of
Final Crisis which basically saw this
massive New Gods story or at least you
know all these major characters from
apocalypse being reborn in human form
after they were obliterated in a war in
heaven against New Genesis kind of a
crazy story the link for Final Crisis is
down in the description if you want to
see it Steppenwolf reappeared well the
problem was that he was killed white off
the bat by the Terra Titans the Terra
Titans are a group that I can't really
say I know a whole ton about I know they
were made in 2008 I know they were made
during the events of Teen Titans number
56 there were the antithesis to the Teen
Titans as you would expect
while Final Crisis was designed to clean
up a lot of plot holes and a lot of
things that had existed following the
events of Infinite Crisis Final Crisis
was designed to basically segue into new
52 in the sense that it was designed to
basically eliminate a lot of these
characters that DC had no intention to
do anything with but that's kind of
ironic because in 2011 when DC came
along and totally relaunched their
entire lineup which is to say they
wanted you to imagine as if they'd never
published a story before a Steppenwolf
returned but the funny thing about this
was that Steppenwolf actually appeared
or really you know made his largest
claim to fame during the new 52 in the
story earth 2 now when the new 52 first
launched in 2011 because of the fact
that earth 2 was designed to be a
reimagining of classic earth 2 which is
to say basically all the superheroes
that came from like the 1940s more or
less in DC's publication history while
people were sort of split on it which is
to say some loved it some didn't like it
it was designed to sell to halves or at
least 1/2 of a major story the first
half of the story was basically Darkseid
invading the main DC Universe in the
sense the dark side was looking for the
anti-life equation now but the whole
idea was that where Darkseid invaded the
main DC Universe Steppenwolf were sent
to invade Earth 2 but with Steppenwolf
invading earth - he was actually a lot
more successful than dark
was when Darkseid invaded the main DC
Universe he fought the Justice League
they basically defeated him and ran him
off and that was really about it they
forced him back to apocalypse with
Steppenwolf succeeding in defeating the
the superheroes of Earth - his actions
actually saw him killing Wonder Woman
and Superman Batman succeeded in
defeating Steppenwolf he lost his life
in the process but Steppenwolf is
Steppenwolf's forces were basically sent
back to apocalypse Steppenwolf himself
remained on earth and it lasted that way
for about five years now in response to
the deaths of Superman and Wonder Woman
on earth - what we ended up getting was
a sword of New Age of Marvel's
quote-unquote so to speak basically
something called the world army which
was essentially this new generation of
superheroes and that was DC going
forward into this new generation of
heroes on earth - taking the earth to
concept and throwing it all the way back
to the original Justice Society of
America from you know the 1940s and in
DC's publication history and so with
that in mind
Steppenwolf didn't really do anything of
any major significance he was just kind
of there for a while he was hiding
underground
he was basically just sort of trying to
stay hidden from Darkseid due to the
fact that failure is usually punished by
death when it comes to Darkseid and then
ultimately he was killed by you know
earth - his version of bizarro but that
was it I mean there's there's really
nothing out there when it comes to -
Steppenwolf I mean there is more history
when it comes to like all the other new
gods then Steppenwolf himself but again
a lot of it was because he was never
designed to be a major character he was
just designed to be a guy who went out
and committed these acts on behalf of
Darkseid Darkseid was the major draw
Darkseid was the big bad guy he was the
big guy you fought to give you guys some
perspective in terms of what this means
for the DC Cinematic Universe in terms
of what a mother's doing if you remember
them in credits seen in Avengers when
you basically had that guy who was
talking to Thanos you know I said well
you can't invade earth you know to do
that as to court death whatever it is a
weird guy with the crazy voice it would
be like if that was the main villain
that the Avengers fought like that's
basically it having said that it's not
the worst thing ever because what this
does is it takes a character that has
marginal history I mean Steppenwolf is
appeared in 150 comics in DC's
publication history 70 or 80 of those
were either encyclopedia comics or
comics written in other languages so all
in all he's probably appeared in like 80
actual comic books like comic books in
general in DC but the whole idea is that
this allows
Warner Brothers to take a villain who
almost nobody knows about and who most
comic book readers don't really care
about and elevate him into somebody that
people can care about that's kind of the
benefit of that it's the Silver Surfer
effect as I like to call it Silver
Surfer first showed up in the original
Galactus trilogy in Fantastic Four he
was just a silver guy on a surfboard who
basically betrayed Galactus and it led
to Galactus losing that was it Galactus
can find Silver Surfer to earth and his
solo series picked up where he was
basically a man on a planet he didn't
know anything about and was learning
about humanity you got to see the world
through his eyes and the philosophical
views that he held is what made him so
interesting with Steppenwolf this
provides Warner Brothers the exact same
benefit the caveat to this is that also
Steppenwolf is not a pushover right I
mean he's a new God so basically he has
all the powers of Superman in a lot of
different ways you super-strong hands
durability he's immune to like all the
diseases he's clearly like a force to be
reckoned with he's a guy that could
probably give Superman a run for his
money depending on how they do it if
they take the earth to version of
Steppenwolf it would probably lead to
him defeating Superman and Sam in the
Superman showed up or it would be a very
clutch battle at the end of the movie if
Superman ever comes back I imagine
they're gonna beat him up they're gonna
make him a pretty powerful character but
again they're basically fighting a
general then I think is really like the
big game DC's shooting for I mean if
this movie plays out the way that I
think it will the Justice League is
going to struggle against Steppenwolf
they're gonna have a difficult time
facing him and then probably at his
defeat in the last moments of his life
assuming he dies or something like that
it'll be like well now you have to face
my master and he's several hundred times
more powerful than I am if you starve it
against me you have no hope against him
that's the feeling that we're probably
gonna have as we come out of it is well
they struggled against a guy like him
and Darkseid is just that much more
powerful then what hope do they have
against somebody like him which may lead
to the introduction of other characters
agree man turns something along those
lines but again first Steppenwolf
himself there's not much to go on
there's very very precious little
information about him out there he was
just kind of a side character he was a
guy who was just there did some stuff
and that was really about it but
hopefully this helped to give you guys
at least some measure of understanding
of who he is you know as best we could
anyway but yeah if you guys are new here
to come as explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rod for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]